welcome to the 4th of July week where we
celebrate our independence we want you
to personally celebrate some
independence maybe you become
independent of your master Master Card
maybe you become independent of Sallie
Mae and you kick the old woman out in
the street where she belongs
maybe you become independent of that car
payment that you've had since God was a
boy unbelievable it's time it's time for
your independence and that's what this
shows about it's about you getting
control of the controllables there's a
lot of things in life you can't control
but an amazing amount of them you can
just by making better choices making
better decisions that usually happens
when you have information and a
different belief system than the one
that led you into stupid I believe some
things that were I believe some things
to be true that weren't true and they
led me into stupid stupid with lots of
zeros on the end and I got a PhD in D
UMB I went completely broke in my 20s
lost everything and God gave me the
opportunity to start over with nothing
after having become a millionaire by the
time I was 26 starting from nothing so
I'm so dumb I had to do it twice surely
you can do it once and we'll show you
how the process of handling money the
process of looking in the mirror and
saying the bad news is you're the
problem
good news is you're the solution and you
can decide what to do
you can decide that you're not going to
believe your broke friends when they
start giving you financial advice broke
people giving you financial advice is
like fat people giving you diet advice
come on think about it it's not a plan I
mean if you hire a personal trainer and
they walk in there 450 pounds we got a
problem here
unless you're wanting to be a sumo
wrestler there's an issue right I mean
that's not who you want training you on
that and that's like you're broke stupid
friend who's deeply in debt giving you
financial advice
he doesn't mean to be stupid she didn't
mean to be stupid but we've all been
stupid at one time or another on
different things haven't we and they're
just in their stupid time it's their
stupid season then you don't listen to
people when they're in their stupid
season you've been married 14 times I
hope this one works but I don't need
your marriage advice ever
you know it's okay I mean you know all
your kids are in drug rehab I'm sorry I
pray for you but I don't want your
parenting advice okay you know what
you've been doing have been working so
let's try to figure out what some find
somebody that's doing something that's
working and just emulate that copy that
do what they do in business we call that
best practices we find a marketing
solution that's working in another place
and we just bring it over here and do it
over here most ideas aren't really that
new nothing on this show is new I didn't
invent any of this this is God's and
grandmas ways of handling money I stole
it from both of them I'm just good at
delivering it for 30 years and when you
have common sense intersect your life
truth as opposed to lies told to you by
a politicized culture with an agenda to
get elected when you have truth and
common sense intersects your life it
changes the trajectory of your life it
did mine changed my life forever
I've never been the same thank goodness
is where I was sucked you don't want to
be there you know so I had to change but
the good news is I get to decide to
change the beauty of 4th of July is it
reminds us that some some guys with
really long muskets and excellent aim
gave us our independence and said we're
free and free is you get to decide I
hope my job will get a different one why
stay work your whole life in 38 years
later spend
every week saying I hate my job change
change I don't like where I am
financially good I'm glad you're here
I'll help you change but you're gonna
make different decisions and broke
people are gonna make fun of your
financial plan and a culture that's lost
its ever-loving mind might not have deep
respect for you who gives a crap normal
sucks you don't want to be normal you
want to be weird you don't want a normal
marriage if you've seen people I don't
want a normal marriage I want my
marriage to be way beyond normal we over
in the land of awesome you know that's
where I want to go I don't want normal
kids I've seen some of your kids you
know you don't want normal you don't
want to conform to people that are
losing be not conformed to this world
but be transformed by the renewing of
your mind and that's what we do here we
show you that you have choices we remind
you that you get to decide
sometimes things interrupt your plan
life happens to your plan I get that but
at least my god you had a plan I was
driving along the interstate the other
day my truck quit working hadn't
happened to me a long time I even broke
down on the side of the road a long time
I pulled over transmission was spinning
out of the thing and I put up in park
and it grabbed it when I put it back in
gear enough to limp off the interstate
get it back over here to the parking lot
you know and but you get to decide how
are you gonna react in these situations
life is gonna happen I don't I don't get
to decide if the transmission goes out I
do get to decide how I'm going to handle
it when it does I don't get to decide if
somebody gets sick sometimes you don't
get to decide if you lose your job but
you do get to decide how you're gonna
react and when we went broke you know
what we had we had some never again
moments never again
well American Express called my house
unless it's a wrong number because I
will not be doing business with any
version of anything this is American
Express after the way they treated me my
wife and our family when we were going
broke and lost everything we owed the
money legitimately but the abuse that
they heaped on us was unbelievable the
abuse that chase and discover and first
card heap on some of you is unbelievable
so have a never again moment don't put
yourself in a position where you ever
have to talk to those morons again we
don't have bill collectors calling our
house you know why we don't have bills
you know why we made choices and it's
not getting those positions ever again
life's too freakin short to put up with
that you get to decide have your own
Independence Day
[Music]